the second huge snowstorm of the month
is one too many for millions of people
in the Northeast hundreds of cars were
stranded for hours on to New Jersey
highways last night more than 900,000
utility customers have no electricity
this morning some have been blacked out
since last weekend when another
nor'easter slammed the region the heavy
wet snow brought down many trees
crashing down causing extensive damage
police say one killed an 88 year old
woman she was in her driveway in Suffern
New York at least two feet of snow fell
in parts of New York New Jersey
Connecticut Massachusetts and Vermont
Don Dahler is in Morristown New Jersey
where there's about a foot and a half of
new snow Don good morning good morning
these are some of the hundreds of
thousands of homes where people are
waking up without power unfortunately
for many it has the additional heartache
of them having had it restored after the
last nor'easter only to have it taken
away because of this snow Laden trees
and tree limbs that took out the
electrical lines from New York to
Pennsylvania to New Jersey a whiteout
winter storm blanketed cities for
millions across the Northeast this was a
common scene tractor trailers jackknifed
across barren highways and cars crashed
into snow banks along Interstate 84 in
Pennsylvania it looks like the cops have
the road blocked off Orson
this is backed up for miles and miles
some drivers were stranded on to New
Jersey highways for more than five hours
[Music]
the Northeastern University women's
basketball team had to push their bus
free after it got stuck in the piling
slush in Philadelphia it wasn't just
snow but thunder snow that rolled
through the region one New Jersey middle
school teacher was struck by lightning
at a bus stop and this house in Long
Beach Island caught fire after it was
struck
but the wet heavy snow has made
conditions even more dangerous for Power
crews trees took down power lines
some of them causing fires obviously got
to take severe caution what kind of
hours have these guys been putting in
they've been working 16 hours a day Mike
Duffy heads this team in Chester New
Jersey they're here as volunteers
helping another department after working
non-stop since last week's storm how
much risk is involved for these guys oh
there's risk especially with this
additional snowfall it's a very heavy
snow you know the trees can start
breaking and limbs can start snapping
coming down so we have to be very
mindful of what we're doing it's
expected to get up into the 40's which
will turn this snow to slush and then
down below freezing again tonight which
will freeze it that's gonna make it
dangerous again for the utility crews
the cleanup is expected to take days
Gayle Thank You Don may be a pain in the
butt but sure it's pretty to look at
thanks a lot dawn